[Música]
hola qué tal cómo están con gusto poder
estar aquí hoy con ustedes en mi alma
máter también y es genial ver tanto
talento reunido con la finalidad de que
podamos tomar conciencia de todo lo que
nos están presentando y que cada
perspectiva nos sirva para para hacer
algo en nuestra área de inclusión
déjame comenzar
con una pregunta y quiero que visualices
bien aquello que te viene a la mente es
lo primero que piensas cuando escuchas
alto rendimiento
tómate unos segundos para visualizar
bien qué es lo que estás pensando
tal vez lo que visualizarse es un equipo
de fútbol a menos que le vayas a ya
sabes qué
tal vez visualizarse un atleta tal vez
visualización equipo de trabajo pero
bueno es un ejemplo que ahora tengo que
hacer otro ejemplo que es lo primero que
se te viene a la mente cuando piensas
carácter fuerte
mentaliza que es lo que pienso a ver qué
imagen visualiza
tal vez este vino a la mente a tu papá y
tu mamá que están regañando así es
alzando las manos irte o tal vez se te
viene a la mente una persona que no es
necesario que se gritado sino que esté
calmado puede ser también y por último
que se termina la mente cuando piensas
en inteligencia artificial
tómate unos segundos para visualizar
listo incluso tomó un momento para
platicarle a la persona que tienes ahí
al lado que visualizas y yo vi a esta
imagen hoy esta otra
por favor levanta tu mano si algo de lo
que viste se asemeja a esto
y
muy bien bastantes gracias
y esta es la pregunta qué porcentaje de
realidad de correspondencia tiene la
inteligencia artificial con todo lo que
vemos en la primera imagen podría ser un
robot no sé por qué pero si el road es
blanco nos transmite cierta paz y estaba
está tratando de resolver algo como que
está pensando
o puedes haber pensado en una interface
con un conjunto de líneas de código que
modelan un algoritmo
o en el caso de un tercero visualizo es
una máquina que es maligna y trata de
apoderarse de nuestro planeta pero que
es la inteligencia artificial bueno hay
una una definición
que lo explica muy bien y es el campo
científico de la informática que se
centra en la creación de programas y
mecanismos que pueden mostrar
comportamientos considerados
inteligentes dale un codazo a la persona
que tienes a tu lado y dile como tú es
decir es el concepto según el cual las
máquinas piensan como nosotros como los
seres humanos
ahora mismo hay cuatro olas de
inteligencia artificial la primera es la
más básica los comportamientos que son
inherentemente más básicos para poderle
ganar a un experto en un juego por
ejemplo la máquina de ibm que le ganó en
ajedrez a kasparov el segundo tipo es de
memoria limitada
puede tomar decisiones basadas en el
aprendizaje del pasado un ejemplo de
esto pueden ser los chats bots o los
vehículos autónomos el tercer tipo se le
denomina teoría de la mente en este caso
la inteligencia artificial
que entiende las emociones y cuál es su
impacto en el comportamiento humano
identifica que una persona
al determinar cierta acción puede ser
susceptible si está enojado o si está
alegre la inteligencia artificial ya lo
extensa y toma una acción con respecto a
ello y el último tipo es autoconsciente
en este caso ya tiene empatía y la
inteligencia artificial entiende y
reconoce su existencia abstrae la
realidad que hay en su entorno y con
base en ello toma decisiones un ejemplo
de estos tres de estos dos tipos del
tipo 3 y del tipo 4 es una película que
alguno de ustedes habrá visto que se
llama yo robot
el robot son y es un ejemplo del tipo 3
y el tipo 4 cuántos de ustedes ven
netflix hay una película muy interesante
que se llama ex máchina entonces es un
ejemplo muy práctico del tipo 4
ahora mismo tenemos un mayor acceso al
tipo 2 es decir con memoria limitada
puede tomar decisiones basadas en el
aprendizaje pasado como lo comentamos y
su principal objetivo es optimizar la
operación percibir los patrones de
comportamiento más sutiles que son
difusos para nuestra mente humana
y es que los seres humanos detectamos
ciertos patrones de conducta por ejemplo
si te quedaste ver con un amigo o con
una amiga y tu amiga es puntual y ya
pasan cinco o diez minutos o quince
minutos o media hora o una hora pues
seguramente dijiste algo le sucedió eso
es muy puntual
reconoces ese patrón de la conducta de
autonomía y pudiste identificar que hay
un evento que rompió con ese patrón de
comportamiento
las mamás son muy buenas detectadas de
patrones de comportamiento y si quedarse
de llegar a la casa a las 10 a las 10
con 1 te marcan y dicen dónde estás
otro ejemplo podría ser
si vas en un automóvil hacia tu escuela
o hacia tu trabajo entonces que hay un
poco más de tráfico
seguramente dice pues tal vez hubo un
accidente o tal vez hubo algún evento
que pudo determinar que esa conducta
continua se rompiera en algún momento
tal vez hay una obra vial tal vez un
semáforo se descompuso o sucedió algo
pero día con día estamos pensando
información y estamos captando ese
patrón de comportamiento en nuestro
entorno o incluso por el clima si hay
ciertas condiciones climáticas podemos
decir va a suceder esto va a suceder
aquello pero ya tendremos una serie de
eventos a los que podemos determinar
pero qué sucede cuando tenemos miles de
millones de datos que provienen de
fuentes completamente diferentes con una
gran cantidad de variables
y es ahí donde la inteligencia
artificial se constituye como un
habilitador muy poderoso cuando lo
ocupamos para resolver problemas
complejos
este motor de decisiones este motor de
algoritmos
con patrones para analizar o cómo en
relativity six le conocemos marvin que
es ese robot que besa y nos ayuda a
detectar estos patrones que son difusos
para nuestra mente de tal forma que
podamos entender qué es lo que sucede
que está sucediendo en esta gran
cantidad de información que si todos
nosotros en esta habitación nos
pudiéramos analizar les aseguro que
podríamos llegar a un buen resultado
pero nos tardaríamos mucho tiempo en
cambio si lo metemos en un motor de
inteligencia artificial si lo metemos
por ejemplo marvin y le preguntamos algo
incluso algo muy complejo él nos va a
poder dar un acercamiento una
aproximación de la realidad de tal forma
que nosotros podamos ocuparlo para
resolver un cuestionamiento muy complejo
esto debido a que el motor de
inteligencia artificial la inteligencia
artificial por sí misma analiza desde
diferentes perspectivas y nos da un
entendimiento correcto de lo que puede
estar sucediendo y que estamos dejando
pasar
de tal forma que a través del análisis
desde diferentes perspectivas
podemos considerar una tendencia que
como lo mencionamos hace un momento
parecía difusa para nuestra mente humana
sin embargo si lo metemos a una máquina
que piensa que tiene facultades de
inteligencia entonces esto puede ser un
habilitador para no para que nosotros
podamos tomar mejores decisiones
eso lo podemos hacer a través de tres
fases y la primera el modelado de datos
es decir vamos a establecer de dónde
provienen las fuentes de datos a pre
procesarlos para que posteriormente en
la fase 2
hagamos un pilote o de los algoritmos
establezcamos las condiciones cuáles son
las métricas que vamos a evaluar y a
través de ello poder tener un resultado
certero
y por último
el despliegue en las unidades de negocio
en este caso le damos resultados a la
empresa y esto visualiza lo para tu
institución o si estás trabajando para
tu empresa para nuestra sociedad como
nos puede apoyar está este gran
porcentaje de análisis visto desde una
necesidad real que tenemos como
ciudadanos
y esta última fase promueve el feedback
una iteración constante para poder
llegar a un resultado muy certero con
índices de efectividad muy altos
pero por qué es importante esto y por
qué la la charla se llama perspectivas
de la adopción tecnológica en méxico
porque dos pilares fundamentales para
medir la competitividad en un país son
la capacidad tecnológica y la innovación
a través de un estudio de varios pilares
se puede determinar qué tan competitiva
es una nación que qué tan competitivo es
un país
en el caso de méxico tenemos una gran
área de oportunidad para poder
implementar condiciones necesarias
rodearnos de un ecosistema que produzca
pensadores divergentes que podamos hacer
con la inteligencia artificial en mi
escuela que como nos puede ayudar la
inteligencia artificial en mi empresa en
el transporte público en nuestra ciudad
a las comunidades más muy vulnerables
porque de eso se trata no voy a adoptar
únicamente la tecnología por sí mismo
sino para traer un beneficio a la
ciudadanía
y que estos pilares que les comento
según el foro económico mundial incluso
puedan servir para habilitar a los otros
pilares la capacidad tecnológica y la
innovación para habilitar y potenciar
por ejemplo el pilar el pilar de la
educación de la capacitación
ya que un requisito básico para que las
innovaciones se traduzca en beneficios
económicos y sociales es que las
personas es decir tú y yo y las empresas
queremos ser capaces de adoptar las
novelas como algo inalcanzable tal vez
si nos preguntaran qué es lo que piensas
de inteligencia artificial ahora
tengamos un poco más de contexto de lo
que significa y no pensar como algo
inalcanzable para que se pueda aplicar y
seguir desarrollando para beneficio de
nuestro entorno y de nuestro ecosistema
hay una frase muy interesante de peter
drucker que dice que un cambio en la
percepción no altera los hechos
sin embargo cambia su significado y muy
rápidamente
a través de esta idea que hoy te
comparto tú puedes tener una perspectiva
y sí sí sí pensábamos de alguna forma
que inteligencia artificial sólo
significaba robots ahora ves que es algo
alcanzable es algo que tú puedes
implementar en tu área de interés y que
no sólo eso sino que pueda tener
beneficios muy importantes como lo
acabamos de mencionar para tu escuela o
para tu empresa
o para tu visión
y en este caso como
como el título de la charla habla acerca
de la adopción en méxico yo te invito a
que seamos un agente de cambios no sólo
en temas de inteligencia artificial sino
de cada tecnología que nos pueda aportar
un beneficio para que nosotros podamos
implementarla y sea de beneficio
asimismo para méxico porque como tú lo
lo dice es un pilar muy importante la
capacidad tecnológica y la innovación
para medir la competitividad pero
también
para el beneficio de todos sus
ciudadanos
[Música]
muchas gracias